une communauté où le temps semble être
figé depuis que l'état d'urgence a été
décrété le 22 novembre quand elle est à
l'arrêt les rues sont vides et l'école
fermé
pour trouver la source
et
dans la communauté
pendant
qu'il faisait encore chaud
son ami d'enfance
la communauté de quelques 911 habitants
tous ont été affectés de près ou de loin
par l'éclosion même la chef de la
première nation Ramona Soderlund
est-ce que
[Musique]
une quarantaine de kilomètres de la dans
la petite ville francophone de on
ressent aussi les effets de cette
anxiété non
c'est dans cet hôpital que les premiers
cas de blastomycose ont été détecté la
docteur Calvo Lemaire à soigner certains
de ses patients est la vitesse à
laquelle est
complètement
malade c'est depuis stabiliser la
docteur et ses collègues il s'agirait
d'un travail de longue haleine les
premiers symptômes d'une blastomycose
n'apparaissent pas avant 3 semaines et
la convalescence peut prendre jusqu'à 1
ans
pieds en
avoir encore pour
identifier la source de 7 éclosion il
faut parcourir près 2000 km et se rendre
à Toronto
c'est dans ce laboratoire que les
échantillons de princesses sont envoyés
on a eu 60 échantillon la semaine
dernière lance le technicien pour
l'instant aucune trace du champignon n'a
été détecté et la tâche s'annonce
difficile explique le docteur James
Scott
spécialiste de la blastomycose au monde
est
possible sur le terrain
et avec lui les risques d'une autre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour l'instant les flocons qui tombent
sur offre donc un répit à une communauté
endeuillé
la chef ça voudrait pouvoir donner
réconfort il peut d'esprit à sa
communauté pour cela il faudrait d'abord
trouver la source de l'éclosion ici
Radio Canada